what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and this is a special
video that we created in collaboration
with pro manga artist Cuusoo Marie a few
months ago we made a video about the
potential child of Mellie Otis and
Elizabeth and what types of powers this
child could have the video was well
received by you guys so we decided to
another seven deadly babies video this
time about the baby of s Kannur and
Merlin in the previous video about the
son emilio de san elizabeth i asked you
guys to follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar and give us
your suggestions for what name we should
give to the fictional son of Melly Otis
and Elizabeth after that we took our
favorite suggestions and put it to a
vote
on Twitter after over seventeen hundred
votes the winning name was Azrael
so from now on we will refer to the son
of Elizabeth in meliodas
the son of wrath as Azrael and we are
going to do the same thing for the child
of s Kannur and Merlin so if you want to
help us come up with a name just follow
us on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar and give us your name suggestions
if you click the Twitter and Instagram
links in the description of this video
you will be taken directly to the post
about the name so just reply to that
post with your submission and it will be
seen and stick around on the anime or
Twitter because we will put the most
popular suggestions to a vote and the
winner will be decided by which option
gets the most votes we work together
with pro manga artist Kazuma to come up
with a concept design for the potential
child of s Kannur and Merlin and you
will see that design come to life during
the course of this video and of course
in this video we will be talking about
all the potential powers and abilities
that this character may have be sure to
check out coos ahmadies social media and
show him some love as well links in the
description and if you like our designs
for the seven deadly babies you can
actually buy the Sun of wrath design and
this new design as a shirt you can't
find these designs anywhere else of
course we created the characters
selves so if you're interested just
click the shirt links in the description
if you do you will also be helping this
channel and now let's get into it and
joining me today is my good buddy
Knox Taku he will be joining me again
just like last time with the son of
Elizabeth and Mellie Otis but this time
we're gonna be talking about the
daughter of Merlin and Eskin or we
decided to switch it up and go for
daughter instead of son this time Knox
yo I am dabbing so hard right now very
excited to be a part of this discussing
the big Sun and infinite woman's child
would you like to begin
oh yeah I think this is one of my
favorite ideas just to talk about I love
I definitely ship s Kannur and Merlin
myself so I would love to see them have
some babies if we look at their powers
we know that sunshine is not hereditary
right so it's not like SK North kid is
automatically going to get this power it
is a divine grace that chose Eskin or
after mile its original owner stopped
being a goddess for a time s Kannur
without sunshine though is just a human
and he's a weak human at that so unless
we count sunshine the baby wouldn't
inherit anything really from Eskin or
well unfortunately we're talking about
if they had a daughter if they had a son
he would have a mustache praised by the
gods but yeah aside from that I can't
see much magic power you know going down
the Armstrong lines for generations on
this one yeah that's a great point I
mean mustaches are a sign of great power
in anime we've got Armstrong we've got
wrath from we have Lord I was getting to
Lord we go
you got it we're gonna piece yourself
knocks you can't just start it with
regal so we have esken or being a human
so that wouldn't help us much but he
does have sunshine so we'll get back to
that later but let's talk about Merlin
for a bid because she is an incredibly
powerful mage and she is the daughter of
a mage so we can assume that the baby
would indeed inherit some magical
abilities from
Merlin is one of the strongest majors in
fact with infinite power infinite not
being hyperbole in the slightest so on
Merlin side vemana shall definitely
spring forth and something else that
should probably be mentioned in regards
to Eska nor would it depend if Eskin or
let's not use this f-word because of
YouTube the monetization bogdan's but
what if they smash during the day versus
if they smash at night
Wow that you've given us a lot to think
about in terms of the philosophy of
escrow and Merlin smashing I'm glad that
you've come to realize my genius here
but let's let's get back to this because
even if the baby doesn't inherit
anything from asking or assuming that
he's human and doesn't have sunshine or
that sunshine wouldn't just go to the
baby the baby will definitely inherit
some form of magical ability which would
be cool but for the sake of this video
being as epic as possible let's assume
that somehow a scanners child inherits
both sunshine and something similar to
infinity the mother's insanely open
magic it's in imagine someone being soul
pea to have both sunshine and infinity
so until this point I was thinking that
ESCA Knorr hero name would be older
brighter but if someone literally had
infinite sunshine that is all right yes
you're right because Merlin as we know
can essentially use infinity to freeze
herself at the same age so she never
gets older but imagine using infinity to
freeze yourself in them up with the one
mode for example so that you can be
insanely opie whenever you want and for
as long as you want and not just for one
minute at noon every day that is amazing
wholly flittered I mean that is soul P
it's crazy like it's infinity plus
sunshine it's infinite sunshine ya know
night hours for this women the only
setback I can imagine for this daughter
of Merlin I'm askin or would be if the
body wouldn't be able to take
that much power so if you know she can
put them she'd be in the one mode for
more than a minute but if she stays for
too long it would really take a toll on
her body so she would still be limited
to some extent although not as much as
Eskin or being just a human although if
she would inherit her mother's mindset
she would be able to calm herself down
to a large extent I can't see her going
berserk as it from like mana overflowing
purely because she's Merlin's daughter
I mean Merlin is the single most
level-headed character in the entire
series I mean everyone else is psychotic
for one reason or another I mean that's
a really good point
Knox and that's something I was thinking
about as well because I'm thinking that
learning to control all of this power
would be the main struggle for a
character such as the child of Eskin or
and Merlin
because we know that sunshine has a
significant impact on both the body and
the personality of Eskin or when he uses
it so I think again I think that that
personality change of Eskin or I don't
think it came from sunshine per se I
think that's how he adapted to the
scenario that he was you know evicted
from his village because he was a
monster so the way he personally
rationalized it is that well yes I am
just fraud too awesome for my village
and he became deep riffles son of a
[ __ ] that we know and love so I do
think though that perhaps some of that
prideful genes can be passed on down the
obstruct lines for generations and
therefore can you imagine someone with
Merlin's infinity power but also a
prideful [ __ ] yeah that would be quite
a thing to watch and I think the
interesting thing about all of this
would be is we can assume that the child
of asgaard Merlin if she also gains
possession of sunshine would have two
sides to her to some extent so let's say
at night she would be more cool wise and
calm have that kind of personality like
Merlin at night let's say but then she
would get more cocky and over the top
during the day and I would love to see
kind of that interplay like you have the
ultimate chill calm Merlin desk girl at
night and then like the craziest yandere
slash tune that you can every match
during the day or she only goes into
crazy cocky mode when she's like really
provoked normally regular calm minded
Merlin s character you know she's
fighting her opponent things are going
nicely she's keeping cool but then the
opponent starts actually winning
potentially and then the opponent starts
making fun of her and berating her
saying oh you fool my power level is
over 9000 I don't see how you can even
have a chance against me
mine is clearly higher than yours what's
your power level a pitiful 4,000 then
she like goes full snap mode and goes Oh
your power level is higher than mine who
said that oh yes so then she would
destroy that enemy worse than you
destroy your pop filters NOx Taku yes I
think personally that obviously this
child would be born Opie to some extent
there's no doubt about that so it's not
it wouldn't be a story if this child was
in a story in the future it wouldn't be
a story of her you know getting stronger
and stronger necessarily it would be
more of a thing where she has to control
her power and also reconcile the
differences in personality in order to
eventually become one balanced and fully
fleshed out character and that would
kind of be the focus of her character
arcs she's trying to reconcile these two
sides of her and this immense power and
control it and what other cool thing is
that we can assume judging by asking or
that she would go from like a normal
let's say slim looking Merlin desk girl
to like this ure builder robbery now I
was just saying how excited I am about
this proposition you're proposing yeah
so we would basically go from you know a
slim Merlin s character to a she-hulk
with blond hair and fiery balls of
sunshine all around her and it's just I
would love to see this in an anime I
don't know I was thinking at night you
have like a lolly walking around you
know one of these like forty five
hundred year old lollies walking around
doing your own thing whatever they come
dummy thick mode engage
I mean that is so anime isn't it like
that would work in an animal yeah
and at night she's all embarrassed of
her height and during the day she's just
like so prideful and boastful just
slapping people around so there you have
it folks the daughter of s Kannur and
Merlin would be I think a fascinating
character to see the powers the but the
potential is endless in terms of their
the powers that the child could have and
you say that the the potential is
infinite yes I would say that the
potential is infinite great job Knox
great job thank you my life has led up
to this moment and it was worth every
minute so alas once again we have a
seven deadly sins character who has a
psychological story that they have to go
through like literally everyone else
that's what makes the series great so
once again Merlin and Eskin or not only
one of the greatest couples ever what
their child will have a dynamic
continuation to their tale yes and this
is definitely really gonna happen and
it's not just our fan fantasies thank
you so much for joining me
Knox taku everyone be sure to check out
Knox talk who's excellent content link
to his channel is down in the
description thank you so much for having
me a pleasure as always discussing
what's going to be taking place in pori
Otis the sequel oh it's gonna be lovely
thorry Otis the son of Melly Otis also a
big shout out to coos Omani for drawing
the daughter of Merlin and esken or be
sure to check him out as well links to
his social media are in the description
show the man some love love food and of
course if you want to help us decide a
name for the daughter of Merlin and
esken or be sure to follow us on Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar and reply
to the link thread with your name ideas
we're gonna take the 4 we like the most
and the most popular ones and have a
poll on Twitter and the winner
the winning entry is going to be how
we're gonna call this daughter of Merlin
and esken or I'm immediately voting for
schmess Kannur but I don't see that
succeeding if you'd like to get this
design on a shirt complete with the text
infinite sunshine and
for this channel at the same time click
the link in the description no one
outside the enemy upper community is
going to have these designs so here's
your chance to show your friends how
much of a nice weave you really are as
always thank you guys so much for
watching for hanging out with us and for
listening if you want to hear more
discussions like this with me Knox and a
bunch of other people could have brigs
from all the anime be sure to check out
our rant cafe anime podcast we have new
episodes every week links in the
description to rank a PHA as well and
until next time see us space cowboys and
stay weird Bab
[Music]